this is not fair this is eternity oh
yeah I know you still gotta have it's
not fair well not fair at all we're just
talking about you turning 50 and how
it's like not fair to the rest of the
world that she looks like this turning
50 I might I feel like I'm turning 25
right well you look like you're turning
25 out there I want to know all the
secrets right I know these kids keep me
young I have to try and keep up with all
these yeah these folks out here she
looks like a kid then what she's getting
down with you know the the winner of the
lab and she has swing Latino from season
I mean there's nothing that's going to
do my buddy Vic and I don't know where
you get all your time from that's the
one thing I want to go it's like the
secret behind the time like how in the
world could you do everything so it's
like well you know what matters I was
just on the phone with all the kids
uh-huh balance an alley just like every
working mama I mean you guys know it's
not it's not easy but you do your best
and you just try to get it all in yeah
and it's gonna be one big party
it is it is it's my party I love it
okay what is it involved where you're
going to a Jennifer Lopez birthday party
you know it's just it's gonna be a big
celebration and there's gonna be I don't
want to I want to say everything but I
don't want to it is really gonna be yes
it's gonna be a concert tour but it's
also my aim is to make it feel like an
intimate party as well like yeah we're
all celebrating together we're dancing
or singing we're having a good time you
know it's just I want to create a
different atmosphere than the normal
just watch me do my thing
yeah I mean I want it to be and I want
it to be interactive I want it to be I
want to share this moment is that we've
been talking a lot about what this tour
should be and what it means
you know how special it is and how
special even this time in my life is and
and and what we want to say and what we
want to share and the things that we the
moments we want to have so we have a
couple of beautiful special things
planned and thank you so we're taking a
bunch of the kids we picked one person
from each season so how many total added
that answer is up there from world dance
17 total 17 we have eight five eight
swing swing Latino and then Briers
joining us one this season yeah
all right so I understand there's
actually gonna be a cake coming out of
every concert maybe maybe maybe not
heard this would be true what is a
birthday party
so there's gotta be a cake it might be
okay okay yes really are you gonna come
out of a cake I don't know you think you
don't even eat the cake though I'm sure
okay I know what you're having
do we will you do yeah after a day of
work like that got that figure from
dancing up there like that right I think
no doubt about it I know so did you feel
because it was the milestone birthday
that's why you wanted to do that you
know hey they called me after I finished
bagans I started getting called right
away to go on tour and I was just like I
don't know I knew I had the movie
posters at the beginning of the year
it's like we'll see but then when I
thought about I said well if we can make
it short and this year is a really big
year for me over the summer we can do it
in the summer when the kids are off from
school it was just like a perfect storm
I was like in it's a big I said we can
all be together we can have like a
special moment and when I could I can
share that with my fans and you know
really I just been on this journey my
life has been about my work and my
family and to have all of that kind of
converge on this you know big birthday
of mine I think what's the perfect it
was a perfect you know yeah
storm and I just feel like it's gonna be
a really really special time I feel like
I need to see you happy birthday early I
know is still two bucks right happy
birthday for two months straight
yeah there's true but I mean don't you
want it a little early a happy birthday
thank you yeah inspiration ten years I
please the one you never age it's not
fair right I know so how many cost me
you know very costume changes
there'll be a lot of costume changes
yeah yeah didn't know they're right a
mill site has added a couple yesterday's
yeah oh oh this woman always challenges
me I think there's been a single
performance I've done with her in the
last ten years where we haven't probably
changed at least twice within a number
yeah literally we always managed to pull
it off but you know that's what you get
you get a look for it in it and
sometimes you blink your eye and then
you open it up and we're like wait she's
wearing something different and how did
that happen that's our goal so how many
total do you how many wasn't uh I
haven't counted for this show yet you
know we're still you know I finished
hustlers just a couple weeks ago so
we've just
and create mode they started a little
bit before me
before I got here and now I'm just kind
of throw myself into this bed of 24
hours a day for the past few weeks and
you know I haven't had time to count the
costume no well and hours how many well
let me just say something about her too
because what we're doing in the time
frame were doing it normally artists
come in and they rehearse for a month or
two alone just to like get this like
she's got we've only been rehearsing two
weeks so she learned her whole show in a
week but I'll be there I'll be ready yes
but how many hours do you do it a day
how many how long will you rehearse
before the 910 your daughter yes she can
see oh yeah I I said she's got her
daddy's voice is Ruth back is that all
natural it or she take lessons no it's
it's naturai mean Emmie always could say
I remember when she was in the crib when
she was a baby she used to be humming
and it like really humming to herself
and seeing and and mark would say she's
singing he's like it feels good to her
it feels good to her soul and to her
like her body he's he was like that and
I was like I said you think she's
singing he goes yeah yeah yeah yeah and
he was right and she's always just since
she was little she could always sing is
she gonna come out on the stage at all
maybe during the tour and the only she
wants to she got home on the I wa I
never you know forced Erin to do
anything like when she want to go to the
limitless video I was very very
like weary of letting her do it but she
was like please mom don't pick another
little girl he's like I want to do it I
can do it I can do it and she did yes
she was amazing it was a special special
moment so I don't know if she wants to
and she feels comfortable it's a big
arena it's different than our Vegas show
it's different than other things that
we've been doing so she a fan about
video I mean that voice is crazy good
yeah I think she's come out of her shell
in the past past maybe a couple years
yeah would you want her to go into the
business
only if she wants to all up there her
because it's a lot of work and it's a
lot of scrutiny and you really put
yourself out there in a way and now in
this age of social media where people
can be so brutal and and and mean at
times you know I don't want to put
herself any more out there than she is
by just you know how she's already she
they're not on social media yet and you
know I would just want her to listen if
she was gonna do it there's nothing I
could do to stop her yeah I know that
from being an artist myself nobody can
stop you she's gonna do it but you know
I would never you know push her in any
direction I always hope her as much as I
can and give her as much counsel and
advice as I can and mentor in the best
ways I know how to navigate so you have
that 20th anniversary coming around of
your first album yes I know
[Music]
I believe it's been 20 years what would
you say to that Jennifer who put out
that album today what'd I say to her
yeah like now that you've learned Oh God
I mean when you're young you take
yourself so seriously you know what I
mean you're just so like you think you
know everything I was like I guess I was
like 28 only my first album came out so
I just thought you know like I just had
it all figured out and you don't realize
until you're in your 30s that you know
nothing and 1940 just start like kind of
figuring it out
so you know you're just like us and just
me it's on it's good I just go wait -
life is good life is great I think this
is actually the first time I've seen you
since your fan page yes I saw you in
white right now works for the wedding
dress
how's the wedding planning going it's
going good good I think you know we know
we have a pretty busy year ahead of us
so yeah you know we are gonna take the
time yeah I think you know there's no
rush till that we really see this as
something that is gonna be forever and
we're gonna
we're gonna just take our time and do it
right and do it not rushed like we
started looking at dresses have you
started to something minute now you get
engaged you start looking right looking
at everything but only when I have time
most of the time I'm working so would
you feel like conservative rigid ooh
phalange I don't know I really don't
know I don't I don't I don't know no I
have to have to see when we get closer
yeah you gonna be gorgeous
Thank You minute next oh that is for
sure go on the bus get on your way
I knew I loved gorges never done Bennett
okay wrapping it up the tour like if you
were to tell everybody your fans out
there what to expect would you say what
would you say I mean I didn't use this
gonna be a special experience it's not
gonna be a regular concert tour it's
gonna be a special moment in my life and
in our journey together and I'm super
excited about it I don't think I've ever
done anything like this and and in
thinking about the tour like I said it's
made me think about like it's made me
think about everything
and I'm just excited to be able to put
something
so elaborate together for this at this
moment I think it'll be something that I
know I'll never forget and I hope people
would never forget - we're gonna be
invited your birthday party's gonna
forget it's gonna be awesome
make sure you go right they will pom
[Music]